very nice Tuesday morning Martin Luther
King you did your last March it's over
we're starting off fresh today do dare
enter this [__] house deep deep deep
in the murky waters understand me today
it's 8:01 [__] tip-top Magoo
uncle Joey's ready to stab a
[__]
walking in with a big dick and a picture
I see on sorry because I don't give a
[__] today you follow me and I suggest
you do the same
it's Tuesday the 16th of January have
two months over and you're still sitting
there like a [__] dudes and BOTS it's
time to get out [__]
I've been up since 6:00 a.m. look at
these [__] eyes those little [__]
Thunder send the picture my eyeball
right to Jeff Sessions right the [__] in
the White House so you could see how
much fun I had the problem with Jeff
Sessions is never got his dick sucked
you don't know how to have fun but [__]
Jeff sessions in a political world we're
talking about you and how you're gonna
make it happen the day after
[__] Thanksgiving elbows and
[__] nothing but your [__] gold
push-ups 22 of those [__] and
get out there look at them straight in
the [__] eye and go eat listen you're
either gonna suck my dick are you gonna
suck my dick cuz I ain't stopping this
[__] charade it's Tuesday
you're following me you're a little bit
better than last week [__] what happened
last week it's this week what happened
[__] rough sniff your [__] fingers
rub your balls whatever you need to do
get that [__] patois of debt and get
out there stab my [__] today
it's Tuesday [__] but Joey enough
enough enough
let's smoke some reefer we got to Larry
og from perennial killing [__]
and we got a [__] fuego this will put
a [__] teardrop in ya anyway enough
with the tape today
look at that little [__] bong hits a
debt
there's the little little baby mule I
look at those head sight yeah you know
why that's the bas Rutten Oh - [__]
trainer you do that 30 times in the
morning
30 times at night you'll be breathing
like a [__] bumpy you follow me you
don't hear the wheezing no more I've
been doing that for three [__] weeks
gets rid of asthma that's how he got rid
of his [__] ass now how can I help me
[__] breathe I've been born away
watch as I've been doing this [__]
breathing thing
jujitsu right and I got a full [__]
date today don't stop but I got two sets
tonight
I got [__] jujitsu play I got two
[__] meetings I gotta meet this dude
- right the baby's got swimming you know
it don't [__] her then but I don't give
a [__]
fifty-five and ready of anyway what's
happened you bad mother fights uncle
Joey I hope you'll listen to the podcast
but [__] your boy Gomez from the skit
allegiance of skanks that's my favorite
Bordeaux Rica in the world beside Rene
and costs y'all you follow me and that's
it just another ho-hum day in Southern
California the sun's trying to break out
but uncle Joey broke out already I was
up at 5:55 ready to stab somebody and
had a [__] apple I had my medication
then I'm ready to [__] rock you
follow me I'm gonna go do a little early
more than right then I gotta meet a dude
then I gotta come back and go for a walk
then I go for jujitsu I got it all
planned out it's a [__] map you
follow me
a man without a plan is not a man
Nietzsche anyway let's smoke a bowl of
this [__] Joey why are you [__]
tormenting me
the church always happen now always
represent and the American flag why
because listen this is it right here
there's the Mafia I'd [__] belong to
the Mafia of us we don't give a [__]
that's a type of American we are we
ain't liberal Republican we ain't
[__] a conservative we aint date with
felons in heat you follow me I don't
give a [__] I don't play by the rules
I'm a half a felon I carry a gun but I
can't vote so the rest is up to you
anyway
smoked this bond of death here and get
this party started oh you see that
that's beauty that's doctor beliefs and
bas Rutten breathing and working
together to make my lung stronger to
[__] get the smoke to go right
through the screen right the way you sit
in Australia right now
two more days and I'm in Austin a cap
city comedy club if you don't know now
you know it's [__] sold out all five
shows I've been pimping out for a
[__] month you know I'm saying don't
come cryin to me now I need tickets or
whatever and then next weekend is not so
bad that's [__] Charlotte baby boy
Charlotte North Carolina we ain't
[__] around the next two weeks
Charlotte and Austin you follow me
anybody he's gone he's [__] Harvey
towns I'm going into savage [__]
towns I smoked another bomb what the
[__] do I smoke three four balls
opposition I gotta get you started on
the right foot today it's a cold world
out there you got to be prepared for
these [__] I mean you got to be
prepared to these [__] let me
taste some all these creepy [__] I had
an easier time [__] hanging out with
criminals because at least at least I
knew what I stand these [__]
here show you the right in a thingy with
the left hand but I'm watching both
hands from day one cuz that's the
[__] ship I came off from you follow
me trust no one [__] these creepy
[__] anyway Joe you're gonna
[__] spar give me a [__] ear beam
all right all right
that's it and that's that
yeah I'm saying tip-top Magoo ready to
[__] go everything is in order the
checklist is ready now I gotta make that
day suck my dick and I suggest you do
the same no [__] waste of time you
follow me you get hit by a [__]
bicycle tomorrow and there you are so
you got to go out there and make them
pay your plan for [__] keeps you want
to giggle go to Starbucks and giggle
with your [__] weak friends what from
the church what's happened now we don't
stop till we [__] get there and then
when we get there we got to protect that
[__] see you can all suck my
dick let's smoke this bowl let's go out
there and I show these [__]
who's running things I ain't taking it
no more you follow me if you get bullied
by a gun what are you bothering me for
what the [__] you got no felonies me I
gotta go to the handball court and buy a
[__] piece you know anyway Charlotte
next weekend the comedy zone Thursday
Friday Saturday don't forget about me
the Church of what's happening now
tomorrow night 7 o'clock Pacific ten
o'clock Eastern Time
and the rest is up to you [__]
you got the world by the balls you want
to sit there like a [__] dunce
that's your [__] call me I'm gonna
leave do but I got a big dick and a lot
of personality and I'm going for [__]
broke today I suggest you do the same to
my Spanish people aren't they oh yeah
they think their mom I picked out I
didn't get my might tell a pinga well
I'm more prone to hire I mean see Kermit
didn't get my mom made yet rule still oh
I see I'm sorry
anyway I love you [__] have a
good they don't take no [__] from nobody
stick to your goals and at the end of
the day tell them all to suck your dick
you got what you needed
you made your [__] point
one more for the road you can't walk on
one leg